[Music]  jennifer lopez and drake continue to  heat things up the 47 year old singer  and her rumored new beau have been  spending plenty of time together  recently and a source tells et J Lo is  quote really happy with the 30 year old  rapper I know the pair sparked romance  rumors in December when they both posted  this adorable pic of them cuddled up  together to their social media accounts  and JLo cancelled an event in miami  florida to spend New Year's Eve in Vegas  with champagne papi the source also  tells ET she's head over heels for Drake  it's a new relationship but she really  likes him she's really into him I really  feel blessed  [Music]  you